[Music]
inside his cramped West Hollywood
one-bedroom Rob Pires is navigating a
labyrinth of databases he's trying to
uncover sources of money and influence
in California politics but it's not easy
the state's website designed to promote
transparency isn't transparent at all
which is what Pirates have set out to
fix the website he runs is called the
California target book
California's Cal access website it's
notorious for being just sort of an
ungodly Byzantine messed it if you have
no idea what you're doing it's nearly
impossible to get any useful information
out of peyer's who describes himself as
95 pounds of concentrated technique has
become an expert on pulling data from
hundreds of voter databases election
filings and campaign finance disclosures
while the state's website can seem
designed to very useful information the
california target book takes that same
information and makes it easy to find
and interpret most of the stuff that is
publicly available but it's just a
question of aggregating it all in one
spot and trying to make it as easy to
digest as possible why is the government
so bad at putting out this information
why you know why is this not a public
function well I mean everyone wants to
run a none campaign transparency but
actually executing it well but you know
that's where entries seems to go away as
far as California there's always been a
steady drumbeat yes can we fix this can
we fix this can we fix this finally last
year they passed a bit of legislation
that would spend something like fifteen
million dollars over the next two or
three years trying to look into the 21st
century and are already worried about
that eating your lunch or do you have
faith that they can screw it up again
well let me just say that yeah I'm happy
to have my system in place in the
meantime ok Pires has built the target
book system from the ground up despite
having no previous programming
experience the 41 year old only joined
the site two years ago after he was laid
off from his job bagging groceries at
Walgreens and while the government
builds its multi-million dollar system
the target book is already proven it's
worth the site actively scanned it
sources for new information notifying
the public as soon as it appears anytime
there's a make a contribution over
$10,000 anytime there's a major
independent expenditure over ten
thousand dollars it'll it'll log it
tweet out the link and do a screenshot
of everything another thing is anyone
that is on a watch list that I have set
up like anyone who spent like over five
million dollars in independent
expenditures in the 2016 campaign
I added their committee number to add to
a list and I'd like to think that day
and get doing whatever I can to try to
make it everything we have more
transparent his efforts have helped
expose the unseemly side of
establishment politics during one 2016
congressional race the LA Times used
pyres data to reveal that candidate
Isidore Hall may have misused hundreds
of thousands of dollars of campaign cash
he was endorsed by all the Democratic
Party establishment he was the odds-on
favorite he was a saving state senator
he ended up getting defeated by a grass
root candidate who in the final stretch
of the campaign managed to raise a ton
from an itemized small donor people he
ended up with something like six
thousand dollars remaining in his
campaign account in over half a million
dollars in campaign debts he might have
a difficult time running again anytime
anytime in the near future Pires
believes radical transparency is the
best method for rooting out corruption
because regulatory interventions tend to
backfire for too many years you've
forged government fail a window again he
bases this belief on the real-world
effects he's seen in California in 2010
the state revamped primary elections to
make them nonpartisan reformers promised
this system would help moderates and
minor party candidates
he said he's storing victory for our
state and file people
Peyer says it's further tip the scales
toward one-party rule all the money that
typically would have gone to the
Republican versus the Democrat
no ma'am I grading over towards so you
know the the moderate Democrat versus
the Liberal Democrat this system of non
partisan elections has if anything
increased the power of special interests
in almost every case you had a Democrat
who was endorsed by the California
Teachers Association in the California
Federation of Teachers versus one who
was endorsed by the California Charter
Schools Association and the Charter
advocates race at the rate accuracy you
have those Democrat versus Democrat
races tended to be the most expensive
ones out there one Bay Area District
assembly race spending by both sides
over the course of the year was in
excess of nine point three million
that's more than any congressional race
in California another popular reform is
campaign finance limits but again Pires
believe such regulations backfire and
actively hurt candidates who aren't
backed by a major party or special
interests I think the problem we're
seeing right now it's it's twofold
campaigns are getting increasingly
expensive they're lasting longer with a
tear with the trend towards earlier and
earlier voting it becomes more difficult
assembling a war chest when you're
limited to something like twenty seven
hundred dollars per transaction and
while at the same time outside groups
you know can come in raise unlimited
amounts is wasting all of this time and
effort and in the end a message can be
overwhelmed by someone coming in on
outside of them taking control it's not
the campaign that they want to run I
think deregulating things is then it
I think we're part of the way there the
problem is it's half-measures you know
right now he's taking the shackles off
of outside groups but it still leaves
them on the candidates themselves so the
candidates are at a disadvantage and
they cannot legally coordinate with any
of these groups that are able to raise
all this all this money you've seen how
the sausage gets made in California
right you know what's behind all the
money do you think that there's a
negative effect of allowing all of this
you know the super PACs and the other
groups in
it's very unpopular opinion to say that
I think that citizens united was
correctly decided I think the equitable
solution would be to just take all the
limits off on candidates allow them to
raise whatever they want and require a
immediate disclosure yeah so anything is
that way you're not going to have these
dark money groups with the campaign
contributions that they don't legally
have to be reported you're able to see
where the money is coming from who is
paying for this message and as sunlight
is a good thing
[Music]